we heading today
san diego cindy golight san diego whales
vagina
[Music]
hey
made it to sd baby
we're out here in san diego man i am
tired they got me driving
i'm going all these peaks and valleys
jay got two different side shoes
is that what you say though the worst
person to drive bro
he plays music like he's an actual dj at
the club they play they play for 50
seconds he talked and they put on
another song
living life up in the fast lane
[Music]
mine still says being built
two doors fly
just some 35 standard
still waiting for mine ford still
freaking waiting for mine
come on
now we're headed to the thick boy
fight club san diego chapter
living life though
[Music]
the bonus the bonus
ain't no thoughts about tomorrow i'm
just living in the moment the moment
the moment fool take a guess what you
wanted on the dash [ __ ] i'm zoning i'm
zoning i'm zoning fast lane
living life up in the fast lane
ready
living life
[Music]
living life up in the fast lane
living life up in the past life
[Music]
out of the house tonight mr david lucas
you see what i got on my shirt right
last night in la jolla baby big boy big
boy yeah
what'd you do today uh recover from
[ __ ] a fat [ __ ]
here we go can't use that
today i actually walked and got some
beautiful views of the ocean man don't
tell about the time you're fishing and
catch [ __ ] oh yeah i went fishing
yesterday didn't catch a damn thing it
was a podcast
found out that the guy is not a manager
at the laugh factory he's
he's a damn he's a damn security guard
an inspiring comedian
and i watched
at least
an hour and a half where for his videos
and him
uh calling the booker and the book are
not answering and
and him telling me that i could probably
get my own night at the laugh factor in
san diego and i'm just
yeah
[Music]
another wedding
last night in la jolla
last i don't want to go
i love it here
we might be back soon
i don't think so how was the bike ride
jay
you know it was fun
you showed them jay's arms from crashing
a little band-aid there
jay decided to go uh over the handlebars
of a bird this weekend bird sucks
what's up
[Music]
brandon what are we doing right oh jeez
i'm glad you asked i didn't think you
would uh we're here for fight companion
number three calabasas fight campaign
featuring brian the kid count rampage
jackson bradley martin and josh thompson
why'd you do this because it's a mic oh
it's a mic yeah buffer cool well good
luck boys praying for you man let's have
let's do this and i have quite the cast
with me it's probably the best show uh
going on right now we got josh thompson
my left
we got brian the kid count finally
making an appearance on calabasas fight
companion
and mma royalty the legend rampage
jackson
and he's super nice in person yeah
really nice he's so nice and of course
my man bradley martin here i can't
follow up after that
you know what i probably should have you
shoot me first
just feel it just feel it
my neck is [ __ ] up
do you see how you got flipped at least
with an idiot like me i know i was
trying not to do it but you know what i
mean
[Music]
like i was trying to do this yeah i mean
you're strong you're very powerful but
you you're still getting
you know that's an example
of you you just got it's also me trying
to like
not right i know i know i understand
you're very strong
we are here with mr rampage leaving the
thick boy studio how was the first fight
companion
it was good man it was cool man i like
those guys they all like real
funny real cool real chill you know i
like that what do you think about the
fight it was a good fight it was
entertainment that's what fight's
supposed to be it was it was um really
entertaining yeah 100 but we appreciate
you coming out get home safe my guy how
great jake paul did i honestly didn't
expect it um i don't know if there's
anything else to say about the guy man
and you want some money tonight i want
some money tonight
a thousand bucks and also i got two
thousand bucks that he still owes me so
i'm collecting three um hopefully next
time he's at my gym so yeah brandon i'm
coming for that money i'm coming for
that money i'm coming for the money for
real you better pay me
everyone heard it and he's out and i'm
out i'm julian
photographer i work for this guy
sean art director work for killer merch
we do everything for thick boy brand
let's do it here we are boys let's go
[Music]
you